all right hey palsies my name is cody
and i'm a helpster that means a monster
who helps and because i love love love
to help so much i'm making these videos
called
helpsters help you
guess what today i am gonna teach you
how to be a helpster so a helpster is a
monster who helps so job one is
be a monster so how do you do that you
might ask well um let's see oh monsters
love to smile so you gotta smile like
this
[Music]
good okay let's see what else oh
monsters can move really fast like this
[Music]
like that and monsters love to dance
like this
and last but not least monsters love to
sing like this
[Music]
oh thank you that's very tiny
congratulations
you're a monster
now job two is to find a way to help and
i have a few ideas you can put your toys
away or put books back on the bookshelf
or hang up your coat or put dirty
clothes in the hamper or or you could
help cheer someone up by playing with
them or if someone needs quiet time you
can help by playing by yourself
or you can do my favorite thing ever
which is
ask someone how you can help
[Music]
excuse me just a moment
hello
cody it's mr prim i am in need of your
help oh well of course mr prim
let me just say goodbye to everybody
first goodbye goodbye to home oh well
you see i i'm making these little videos
right now and i just wanted to tell
everyone watching to make sure they help
the people and monsters around them
because everyone loves a helping hand
hmm
i i believe you just did tell them that
oh yeah
see you next time everybody helpsters
help you